バンキラジオご飯ご飯ご飯ごちゃんひこ
特性ひかちゃん杯
よいただき
[拍手]
ます辛すぎるってあらそ夏だしビリカで
いいじゃない激辛なんだよ要は大激辛
ブームなのよあ私才能あるかもしれない
から中華流で開いてみよっかなはどうぞう
ちんこの業種回転ですみんな入って入って
なんで俺も売上は分けるから手伝いなさい
お腹が空いたんだな
も中華料理いいねほら入って入って入って
入っ
て中華料理は辛くと熱いのが大事僕ほどの
仲介で降りるとなるとよっぽど辛くない限
満足しないぞはい黒円魔豆腐
ですガ
こんな辛さ経験したことがない最高だほら
見てお母さん俺の言った通り普通に作った
だけなのにカウ
[拍手]
から梨よしみという番組に出演して
いただけないでしょうかテレビ番組出
ますあんまり調子に乗らない方がいいよ
今回のチャレンジャー
は頑張ります女優
といやいやいや俺行っちゃうよガチで行く
よお笑い芸人の出川手哲郎やってきたのは
東京にあるキーコの玉勝今回チャレンジ
するのはお店の看板メニューでもある超敵
から流しラーメンデソース
にリザードンの尻尾を入れて完成果たして
2人は完食できるの
かいただきますいやいやいやいやいやああ
辛そううんわあこれは辛いいやいや
いやいやいやいや
うんやばいよやばいよこれリアルガチで
やばいよこれ作ったスタックがバカか
いやいや
いや可い
よいやいや俺よもうこんな食えないよバカ
だよこれ作ってやつこれリアルだからマジ
ですいません私ギブアップで2人ともギブ
アップだガチでやばいよガチでなぜこんな
激料りが作れるんですか辛さを研究し
尽くした結果ですそれやばい
よ店ですえ
えやっ
たみ
[拍手]
楽しみありがとうござい
[音楽]
ますすいませんうテレビで材です取材させ
てください
[拍手]
材もしかして私のお店って売れてる
[音楽]
おお母さん1000万も儲かったんだから
俺にもお金分けてよ私の料理で稼いなんだ
から私の金
を聞いてた話と違うじゃんあなたグビ
はあ見てみ
なさいでののさんです最近はカップ
焼きそばの鬼から焼きそばが全国的な大
ヒットですよねロもこも
こもきこの王将鬼国撃から焼きそばおどう
[音楽]
だこれはまるちゃんともちゃんにも食べ
させたいなおいでおいでおいでおいでお
いでおいではい
ンこ
大物Youtuberも大切なんですね
そうですねもはや私が中華料理の顔になっ
てしまいましたね中華料理とは辛さである
スパイね私が人気になって私の力で売れた
のあなたは何もしてないわ必要
なし調子に乗ってると痛い目にあう
[音楽]
くだだめです新しくできたキーコの玉勝に
客が全部流れちまってます
者しねだよはい警察してき
ますちゃん
です豆腐も1個
マボ
[音楽]
マボマボマボおいしく
なれ好きだらけじゃねえけ
これでおしまいだ
あ
誰ごめん
[音楽]
なさいどうしたボスあいつは相当強いです
よ
あえじん
ちゃ
[音楽]
え誰の仕これじゃお店が回転できない
わまだ匂いが残ってるわ
ねこっちね
[音楽]
嫌がらせしたのはあんただね一体どこの誰
よ俺たち
は中華料理負
だお前が中華料理に喧嘩を売ったんだ
やうわ
あらおあらら
[音楽]
らこれでお
ハゲだつ誰おしまいだよお母さん
[音楽]
大らみんな
ありがとう最高だ君が話を持ちかけてくれ
たおかげだ
くそあいつのところ
がくそくそくそくそくそくそ
くそ
ほ僕もお母さんにむかついてるんな一緒に
お母さんを倒して売上約1000万を
山分けしよういいあん
だ全力で
潰そうはい山明けやっ
たややったやったやったやったやったやっ
たっっっゃゃむにゃむにゃやったやっ
たとどをしっかりさせ
はいおりゃむにゃむにゃ
えなん
だうわ
[音楽]
おお母さんがお酒を飲んで水けを使ってる
んだ
何
あ
ガ
え杉
たち
はい我々の負けだすまなかったいやいいの
よ私も迷惑かけたみたいで申し訳ないわ
そうだ仲直りの印にみんなでご飯食べ
ましょうよいいね
じゃあいただきますいただき
[音楽]
ますみんな喜んでくれてよかったいつも
より辛く作ったから
ね
から
パ
ちゃちゃチャンネル登録チャンネル登録
チャンネル登録よろしくチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録
よろしくチャンネル登録チャンネル登録
チャンネル登録